hello everyone I had a couple of
suggestions already to make a video
about the greatest Brazilian chess
player ever
Henrique making also known as Makino
after Bobby Fischer's retirement in 1972
Henrique making was considered to be
definitely one of the contenders for the
crown in 1977 he was ranked number three
in the world behind world champion
Anatoly Karpov and second Viktor
Korchnoi and well he probably as he want
to introduce on tournaments he never
managed to win the candidates but well
at the peak of his power he was struck
by a very very well deadly illness I
don't know the name of the this illness
but it's some sort of a long-term
neuromuscular disease which affects
pretty much everything so some some
thought that he would even die but he
managed to beat the this illness but he
didn't play chess for ten years but even
today at the age of 65 I believe he's
still considered not consider he is
still the strongest Grandmaster or chess
player in Brazil so let's see the game
the game was played in 1971 in Mar del
Plata he's playing against Miguel Nye
Dorf and well it's always fun when
someone plays against night or friend
night or goes for the night or variation
the tournament was won convincingly by
love polo is key with 13 points out of
15 but this game cost night or second
place as making really did a number on
him so making his has the white pieces
and he plays efore we're c5 the Sicilian
defense Knight to f3 d6 d4 C capture
Sunday for Knight captures Knight to f6
Knights
Knight to c3 and neither goes for the
knight of variation a6 Bishop to g5 we
have e 6f for 57 Queen to f3 27 this is
still the main line of the night or
making castles we have Knight B to d7
Bishop to e2 and here if night off would
have continued would be five this would
still be the main line
the neither variation but neither
decided to mix it up he goes for rook to
b8 and this well this will support the
b-pawn nicely after a night or starts to
push the pawn but this also allows
making to well to make his attack happen
even faster so he goes for g4 with b5
Bishop captures on f6 Knight captures on
f6 and g5 937 and now Bishop to d3
before is played Knight c3 - and now
Knight to c5
attacking that light-square bishop also
this queen is eyeing this King and c1
rook h2g one is played and now g6 we're
at 5v5 they're kicking the night away
from d4 Knight to b3 and now Knight
captures on d3
Queen character son b3 and Bishop to d7
we have f6 Bishop to b5 now first would
attempt on the Queen Queen to d2 and now
Bishop to d8 ninth to g3 and well in
this position
neither of King is perfectly fine in the
center actually there's there's no
immediate danger of of capturing this
pawn on d6 because well what would get a
very nice attack from this so probably
probably probably pushing a 5 and a 4
would be definitely a good plan for
neither but now you've decided to castle
and well instead of instead of going for
this this exponent as well if you
capture the pawn with Queen captures on
d6 you get Queen captures on d6 Brooke
after Sun d6 and well after Bishop to d6
for example or Bishop to c7 black will
get black would get sufficient counter
play for this d6 pawn though these two
these two bishops are extremely powerful
here but making didn't really want to go
for this anyway so after a night of
castle
he immediately transferred the attention
to the Kings side with
Quinta g2 and of course making the idea
is now he wants to play Queen h3 Queen
h6 and Queen to g7 checkmate
this would be lovely if he could achieve
this so neither goes for rope to c8 now
making Queen to h3 impossible because
Queen captures on c2 would be checkmate
we have came to be one and now Queen
captures on C 2 will not be checkmate
and nitro has to play Queen to d7 now
stopping making squint to go to 83 but
here making gets a very interesting idea
he plays Knight to f5 with the idea well
sacrificing a knight so if G captures on
f5 this would block the Queen's well the
Queen's attack on the h3 square
neither of characters the knight G
captures on f5 and we have Queen
captures honey sorry Queen to h3 now
again with the idea of Queen h6 and
Queen to g7 checkmate
we are King to h8 now with the idea that
if Queen to h6 then work the g8 stopping
Queen g7 and we have he captures on f5
neither plays Bishop to e2 and this
Bishop to e2 isn't with the idea of
grabbing this rogue this is actually a
defensive move rook to g3 and we have
Bishop to h5 and night off wants to give
up this light square bishop so if Queen
captures Bishop then Queen captures an
f5 and the well neither of his defending
this white is still better but at least
he stopped the attack at least for a bit
but after Bishop to h5 making isn't
interested in this Bishop plays rook to
f1 a much stronger move defending his F
pawn and now threatening to capture the
bishop we have Queen to b5 and neither
of attacks this broken f1 rope to f2 now
Queen to b6 again attacking the rook on
f2 and now rook F to G 2 by making Queen
to b5 again with some ideas of Queen to
f1 check and well capturing this bishop
now would be perfectly fine perfectly
fine for
but he plays a very aggressive move he
plays g6 and although capturing the
bishop would have been better and making
is still better in this position but
this does give neither of some counter
play we had F captors and g 6f capture
sin g6 and Bishop captures on f6 as well
g7 was a pretty terrible threat Bishop
captures on f6 and now Queen captures on
h5 Queen to f1 check night the c1 and
rook to c7 now defending g7 check and
making place G captures on h7 and
although it seems that White Knight off
is getting completely crushed here with
a move like Bishop to g7 this would
actually give him pretty good chances
but as they were both in time trouble
here Miguel night off actually makes a
pretty big blunder
he played rook captures an e7 thinking
that well he's perfectly fine here but
he actually allows an 18-3 with Queen
captures on h7 check sacrificing the
Queen King captures on h7 and our rock
page three check and in this position
Miguel night of resigned the game
because the only move is Bishop to h4
and our rook captures on h4 it's
checkmate the King has nowhere to go so
yeah a very nice game by the Brazilian
Grandmaster Enrique making and well they
say that well in those days and for
example 1977 he was so popular in his
own country that well they often
compared him to to paly in soccer or
Emerson in Formula One and his face was
on the cover of many magazines and like
I said even today after a very long time
of being inactive in chess he's still
the strongest player in Brazil so yeah
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
I would like to thank mikaël Hildebrand
and the Jack fent for contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it
as usual you can check to all my
previous videos here thank you all for
watching and I will see you soon